honestly a great movie to watch
it's one of the funniest movies ever
[__] made it's a Mel Brooks movie
It's called Young Frankenstein I've seen
that yeah he was the he was the yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um but big I'm big movie guy if you go
if you're in the movies oh that's why
you know I I don't think I don't know if
this is racist but when you asked what
what type of Asian you were yeah uh I
kind of based I'm really in a Korean
film and I just kind of you reminded me
of some of the actors I've seen [__]
yeah man in those movies yeah music Choi
where's their poster that's my favorite
movie oh you have that in here yeah it's
over there
where the [__] is it there it's right
there behind you that's one of my I mean
probably my top number one favorite
movie ever that's what that's that movie
I gave to Bill Burr years ago on DVD and
he goes [__] you gave me an Asian movie
right and I remember him a couple of
months later calling me and gone bro
insane yeah it's a great [__] movie
it's such a tune I want to hear some
because I don't I've probably seen I
mean I've seen all the clap like
parasite I've seen I've seen um train to
Busan you know what I mean but maybe you
can recommend some deep cuts
uh here I'll just name some off yeah it
was the whaling yeah
wow that it was such a great movie yeah
insane insane uh what else is there
mother great movie Memoirs of a murderer
classic okay yeah yeah okay I saw the
devil one of the best it's a mix of
choice in that too okay yeah those are
like the ones that come to mind right
away there's definitely some deep Cuts
I've seen let me ask you if you retained
a girl and she got I don't like Asian
movies I was gonna say that deal breaker
like the one of the tests is like
sending over some of those and a lot of
people just don't even like to watch a
movie with subtitles like yeah you
haven't done it yet you haven't seen
oh boy you haven't seen one of some of
the bangers city of guys any girl ever
said that to me
you're [__] out in fact I'm gonna
hurt you not physically but mentally you
know what I mean or don't do that I'm
not gonna even do that or not I'm not
gonna hurt you at all
I'm not gonna accept it either I don't
have to accept it but don't call me
again is that cool yeah yeah you're
right great answer I went too far yeah
I'm not gonna work too far way too far
right just don't call me again right
because it's like one of those it's
another here's another one is you know a
girl if a girl goes I don't like seafood
not that they're allergic right that I
won't do sushi like if that was is that
a red flag for you
uh well I actually grew up not liking
seafood at all
I know friendship over but I but I
started see I started figuring it out I
started I Love Sushi and I love like
Crustaceans but I can't really I can't
really get down I can't really get down
with like a salmon slab you know I can't
really do that
you know when they just yeah yeah maybe
it's more Midwest but they'll serve you
like walleye or like filet yes I love
walleye I just I can't get into that
that's a sandwich I meant like a full
steak of of fish but yeah I Love Sushi
it's cooked okay maybe that's what turns
me off I don't know I like I like like
tuna tartar and everything so I but I
used to not like seafood caviar that's
weird whoa I think I I don't know as a
business person and just growing up like
you know being very frugal I I just
think about every bite is like 10 bucks
oh I see I see I see it's yeah that's
what it is it doesn't feel worth it yeah
but whenever like there's an option of
like two you know two different kinds
you always we went to one that was like
I think we were in Andrew and I were in
Indiana or something and one of them was
385 and then the other caviar was 75
I'll take the 75. because I'm not gonna
know the difference yeah absolutely yeah
no because I haven't been eating caviar
that long yeah I'm not gonna eat the 385
and go oh this is a lot more deeper in
texture yeah but maybe it is yeah and
and saltier and oakier okay you know
what I mean like there's no way I'm
gonna no it tastes like fish eggs yeah
and I'm also really like impressionable
if someone would be like well this is
that I'll believe what they're saying oh
what you're saying is that if they
brought up the 75 one but you they
charge a 385 yeah I'd fall for it yeah
me too I would fall for it yeah I know
nothing about caviar but I like it yeah
so so Seafood is not that of a red flag
for you then no it's not okay I mean for
me it's with food I don't know that's
red flags the movie the movie thing is
Big actually with that 410 girl I she
initially didn't want to watch any Asian
movies and so I eased her into it with
uh everything everywhere all at once
because there's a lot of Asians in this
movie yeah and uh you know maybe this
will be a good start and she loved that
so then I got her to watch uh old boy
and it kind of worked out it did yeah
yeah she got into it you just kind of
got a that's a big jump yeah from that
to that yeah I don't know I just she was
like I haven't really seen Asian Cinema
like I think I just kind of convinced
her that it was by Asian directors I
don't believe it is everything
everywhere all at once uh it is yeah
directly half the brothers yeah okay
okay got it I got it yeah half the
brothers are let me ask you I'm going to
see something I'm sorry I have the Bro
half the brothers or sorry uh half the
duo okay got it yeah
I let it go but I was gonna edit that
out yeah that was [__] insane what
you just said um let me I'm gonna say
something so we're not first date and if
a girl said you know what I like
anything sci-fi or fantasy like none of
those movies like [__] it I I can't
watch it it's stupid with dragons and
[__] is that a red flag I just don't
care why like why like why can't you
just give it a try I'll watch anything
you know
that you know man although I don't like
Colonial movies
you're right like you know like when
it's like you know Dangerous Liaisons or
like you know Colonial 17th 18th English
society I love that like yeah I know
what women love that [__] like fantasy
Barry Linden or something yeah whoa